in other videos we introduce ourselves
to the idea of a density curve which is
a summary of a distribution a
distribution of data and in the future
we'll also look at things like
probability density but what i want to
talk about in this video is think about
what we can glean from them the
properties how we can describe
density curves and the distributions
they represent and we have four of them
right over here and the first thing i
want to think about is if we can
approximate what value would be the
middle value or the median for the data
set described by these density curves so
just to remind ourselves if we have a
set of numbers and we order them from
least to greatest the median would be
the middle value or the midway between
the middle two values
in a case like this we want to find the
value for which half of the values are
above that value and half of the values
are below so when you're looking at a
density curve you'd want to look at the
area
and you'd want to say okay at what value
do we have equal area above and below
that value and so for this one just
eyeballing it this value right over here
would be the median
and in general if you have a symmetric
distribution like this the median will
be right along that line of symmetry
here we have a slightly more unusual
distribution this would be called a
bimodal distribution but you have two
major lumps right over here but it is
symmetric and that point of symmetry is
right
over here and so this value once again
would be the median another way to think
about it is
the area to the left of that value is
equal to the area to the right of that
value making it the median what if we're
dealing with non-symmetric distributions
well we'd want to do the same principle
we would want to think at what value is
the area on the right and the area on
the left equal and once again this isn't
going to be super exact but i'm going to
try to approximate it you might be
tempted to go right at the top of this
lump right over here but if i were to do
that it's pretty clear even eyeballing
it that the right area right over here
is larger than the left area so that
would not be the median
if i move the median a little bit over
to the right
this may be right around here
this looks a lot closer once again i'm
approximating it but it's reasonable to
say that the area here looks pretty
close to the area right over there and
if that is the case then this is going
to be
the median
similarly
on this one right over here maybe
right over
here
and once again i'm just approximating it
but that seems reasonable that this area
is equal to that one even though this is
longer it's much lower this part of the
curve is much higher even though it goes
on less to the right
so that's the median for well-behaved
continuous distributions like this it's
going to be the value for which the area
to the left and the air to the right are
equal
but what about the mean well the mean is
you take each of the possible values and
you weight it by their frequencies
you weight it by their frequencies and
you add all of that up
and so for symmetric distributions your
mean and your median are actually going
to be the same
so this is going to be your mean as well
this is going to be your mean as well
if you want to think about it in terms
of physics the mean would be your
balancing point the point at which you
would want to put a little fulcrum and
you would want to balance the
distribution and so you could put a
little fulcrum here and you could
imagine that this thing would balance
this thing would balance and that's all
comes out of this idea of the weighted
average of all of these possible values
what about for these less symmetric
distributions
well let's think about it over here
where would i have to put the fulcrum or
what does our intuition say if we wanted
to balance this
well
we have equal areas on either side but
when you have this long tail to the
right it's going to pull the mean to the
right of the median in this case
and so
our balance point is probably going to
be something closer to that
and once again this is me approximating
it but this
would roughly be our mean
it would sit in this case to the right
of our median so let me make it clear
this median is referring to that the
mean is referring to this
in this case because i have this long
tail to the left it's likely that i
would have to balance it out
right over here so the mean would be
this value right over there and there's
actually a term for these non-symmetric
distributions where the mean is varying
from the median
distributions like this are referred to
as being skewed
and this distribution where you have the
mean to the right of the median where
you have this long tail to the right
this is called right skewed
now the technical idea of skewness can
get quite complicated but generally
speaking you can spot it out when you
have
a long tail on one direction that's the
direction in which it will be skewed or
if the mean is to that direction of the
median so the mean is to the right of
the median so generally speaking that's
going to be a right skewed distribution
so the opposite of that here the mean is
to the left of the median and we have
this long tail
on the left of our distribution so
generally speaking we will describe
these as left skewed
distributions